l'herbe pousser dans ce qui était
important c'est de nettoyer puis qu'il y
avait dans les ateliers
ensuite la ville est là elle a refait
toutes les toitures qui s'était effondré
donc il fallait mettre les usines hors
d'eau
et nous maintenant notre boulot c'est de
remonter petit à petit les ateliers à
l'identique telle course contre la
montre bien drones us
aujourd'hui on était onze on je vais les
vols nous avons une cinquantaine de
machines que l'on va tout refaire à
l'identique bien entendu pour les
restaurer et les pouvoir les réutiliser
ultérieurement
mais pour ça il faudra des petits
moteurs qui on pourra adapter aux
systèmes pour le permis pour permettre
de le faire à marche et copines le
marché avec la turbine pour faire
tourner les poulies il y avait le bruit
de lusine et même à l'extérieur on
entendait quand l'usiné météo marque
on attendait que tel s'arrêter depuis
l'extérieur
rob s'est installé ici parce qu'il avait
la main deux et il avait également la
matière première est à dire dans les
forêts alentour on allait couper le
merisier qui allait servir à faire les
couples à lasser le bureau du chef
d'atelier
c'est à dire que mon grand-père
travaillait ici enfin également c'était
lui qui manageait l'ensemble des équipes
la mécanique l'atelier principal la
galerie les les anglaises etc
[Musique]
une des difficultés c'est le fait qu'on
soit en 2000 en dalles sur le bureau ici
c'est la hauteur de l'eau en 1956 156
donc tout l'atelier était inondé il
avait été obligé de mettre les machines
sur des palans pour pour éviter la
catastrophe
dans le cadre du partenariat qui a été
signée entre la municipalité et le lycée
certaines petites machines à venir parce
qu'ils s'y soient emmenés au sein des
établissements
c'est des élèves de bac pro maintenance
des équipements industriels et donc il y
interviennent sur on appelle ça du
grattage et des grippages donc eu
nettoyage simplement de machines
industrielles anciennes
on a eu l'exemple dans les années
antérieures leurs prédécesseurs qui sont
qui se sont re motiver et qu'on a réussi
à raccrocher à la discipline grâce à ses
interventions
sapad rockeur franchement est-ce que
c'est un patrimoine à me tient
énormément au groupe n'est mieux son
bateau mais on est des combattants nous
sommes tous des gens qui ont plus de 70
ans
il faut absolument qu'il y ait à
renouvellement et que les jeunes
s'intéressent à cette à ce patrimoine
[Musique]